hey guys this is andrew for
childrenscences.com so i've been working
as a professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong
and i've decided a few months ago to
create my
youtube channel i want to discuss here
guys with you all the different tools
and techniques that i use at work that
work for me
and i want to show you how to use it
yourself so if you want to know about
all the stuff you guys are in the right
place
and today i want to make an update on
amc let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so this is the amc chart
on the four hours time
frame the best time frame to use like i
always tell you because it was used by
short-term traders and long-term
investors so let's first
have a look at the technicals i was
telling you guys that you know
i'm not oldest like the past month i was
telling you guys i'm not
bullish on the short term you look at my
idiot wave counting
i'm bullish on the long term despite
what i'm gonna show you guys
that is just insane i'm talking here
about the show's emissions
but first here just technically speaking
we have what we can call a breakout not
confirmed yet but we have a breakout
so first let me come back to what i was
saying so i was not
bullish guys because you know i i was
waiting for my abc
you know and to have a c wave complete i
needed to have
my abc summary complete i need to have a
c wave that is actually going lower than
the a wave
and my level was 7 15. we didn't go to
750 which is not a problem
the abc zigzag correction might still
be finished why i'm saying that few
things
first my macd turned green so the macd
is a very early signal it's not because
it's turning green that the price
actually would revert but it's just
telling you guys
that it might actually revert very soon
and what i like to use what is very
efficient that i use every day guys
is uh you know those kinds of trend line
once you have identified a wave
that's why i use idiot wave counting and
for those who want to know more about
idiot wave counting
just click on the link in description of
this video you're going to receive a
free video where i explain everything
about that that is actually coming from
a book
you know it's not my theory it's illegal
uh wrath as an idiot theory
and it's just amazing stuff that i use
every day since
uh i've discovered it here i do my waves
so i can do my trend lines all right so
here i have my trend line
and i'm going to show you different
things here as always when i
do my analysis on this crazy stocks you
know where you have more than 100
movements on the the screen you're
watching so here we go from five to
twenty so it's like you know full time
three hundred percent
i have here then i use a log scale and i
do my trend lines during
using a log scale so if i do that here i
connect
you know let me just show you i do it
well i connect here this high
okay i'm perfectly on it
and this one
and you can see that on the first time
frame once again
we closed above we didn't confirm the
second one
is below so we are trying to break out
we are not breaking out
so for now the breakout is not confirmed
we need
two more candles again to trade above
but i have a green magazine which is
going to push some investors to buy you
know
some people that just follow those
magnus signal blindly
and that's why i like to keep an eye on
the macd
is because i know that those guys
they're gonna step in the game and
start to buy some shares just because
it's it turned green you know it's a
strategy they're just used on many
different stocks
and they help the price action to be
higher whenever the market turns green
so i know those those guys are gonna
come
uh i know that we have the expiry coming
as well so let me
show you quickly what we have on this
expiry
all right so uh for amc right now we are
at um let's say nine so look at this
the synthetic short exposure where is it
concentrated on the 10
level so how many shares do i have on
the 16th of april expiry 10 i have
57 000 shares and on the 11 i have
40 000 you can see you know it's where i
have the most
concentration 57 000 here 40
000 here until the fifth the the 15th
level so
all of this so for now you see those
have zero delta once again i use this
formula to
compute my delta i'm not gonna go
through this
again with you if you're interested go
check my previous videos i explain
exactly how to do it yourself
it's very easy guys actually it's a very
basic mathematical formula that you just
need to apply
and you can compute the short interest
and
so you can see that those 13 14 even the
11 it has almost zero delta so what
what is gonna happen if we go above that
if you go to 13
the short interest grew from 200 million
to 500 million right
so this is you know quite quite a lot
actually for
a price like amc you know basically
number of shares the market makers are
going to need to buy
you see the delta is now from zero
it went to 14 and you know if we go
much above that i'm just going to show
you the delta is you know converging
to 100 so basically what this means
right now the 11 strike is at six
percent is that
all these shares they're gonna need to
buy it all right
so they're gonna need to buy 140 000
uh shares on the market so they're gonna
just if we go higher this is what is the
gamma so this is gonna create some
bullish momentum if we go
higher as well you know that's why i'm
talking here about momentum
so i think the breakout can uh actually
happen
here and once again my abc is finished
so why not seeing a breakout now
something i really want to show you guys
is that
gme is that high you know because they
have not
emitted any shares but look here i
recall the short interest the
outstanding number of shares and the
equity float
and then i compute my short interest you
know it's just this formula
i divide the short interest by the
equity float and for amc guys
you can see that between the 15th of
december and the
30th of jan they emitted you know
they were they went from 100 to 400
million shares all right
so basically the number of shares
has been multiplied by
4.8 you need to keep this in mind you
know for example gamestop guys
it has not been like this they were at
47 they are only at 53
guys all right they are just doing
emission very very calmly quietly you
know they are not desperate for cash
amc is desperate for cash so this is
telling me guys that
they're gonna just keep putting a
selling pressure on their price
so my targets are still valid you know
but
it will really depend on whether or not
they keep emitting shares if they keep
emitting shares i heard
there is you know a rumor they're gonna
emit 500 million shares
okay so there is a rumor they're gonna
meet 500 million shares will amc
issue 500 million new shares we don't
know
we don't know but you know people here
discuss this
they need to have shareholder approval
so i'm not sure they're going to have it
but you know between having a very
expensive debt because the debt is not
you know for free
for a company like amc that is you know
a target for hedge funds that
you know you don't lend money to this
company without
a big interest rate in return so they of
course prefer to images
for free and this is what they've been
doing for the past
three months and if they keep doing this
they're gonna keep putting a very
high selling pressure on the price so of
course my targets
are assuming they don't emit more shares
but even you know we know that we know
that there is a rumor they're gonna name
chess
still guys we're having this kind of
breakout
on the upside that is happening so watch
out what is gonna happen here
if we break this once again two
consecutive candles under four hours
time frame
we are bullish and probably gonna go you
know much much higher like i'm talking
about 50 100
higher especially with the expiry coming
on the 16th of april
if we don't break break it out we might
still
go to the initial my initial target you
know on the short term that is
7.50 and then of course the rebound will
would eventually occur because uh this
stock has a lot of bullishness
as you can see guys despite the five
times dilution
that they did that the firm did on their
own shares
we are turning around 10 when we were
trading around
when they started 15th of december
around three
all right so let's say five so we should
be trading at
one just taking this into account we're
turning in nine
so you know it's like around eight
hundred percent higher
so amc is just flying so it's gonna
probably keep flying i mean you know
when a stock goes higher
it is for some reasons that i'm
convinced are still
there and i'm still bullish on the stock
whatever
the news of new shares emissions are i'm
gonna keep you guys updating on
everything i find
and watch out this breakout level you
know 950. so if you guys enjoyed this
video please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show see you guys